hello
hi can you hear me Avery I can hear you
can you hear me yeah yeah good yeah uh
what's happening what's the topic what's
the yeah what's
the
right where do I start with that
one yeah it's well obviously firstly I
think you've already heard that it's
what was given to ISA that's I keep
hearing but nobody's telling me what was
given to Issa specifically what was that
you know like like the contents the
details of it
yeah so I'd say it be like it' be
similar to the Quran you know like
worship one God fasting establish the
prayer give charity you know be good to
like you know even in the Surah Mary
Surah maram you know when Isa was a baby
when he's speaking these are the things
he like goes on to confirm would that
would that be in
theil since that's Isa is speaking and
and the angel was revealed to him that
yeah he would extrapolate it from there
yeah but how do you know
then because the Quran doesn't say that
those things that Jesus said as as an
infant would be in the angel or whatever
he doesn't he doesn't tell us that you
know so how do we know like for example
everything that Muhammad says isn't in
the Quran right what Muhammad says some
some of the Revelation is in Hadith it's
not even in the Quran right so how do
how do you know that what Jesus is
saying would correction firstly that's
not Muhammad s Al is saying that is that
is Allah saying but he's been commanded
to save AER him well well similarly
there's Hadith where Muhammad is saying
what Allah said there Hadith like that
yeah Hadith yeah so similarly to the
Quran no but but them sorry them words
they're not like you know word for word
by Allah they're like the inspiration is
there but like the prophet is putting it
in in in his own words how do you know
that they're not word for word from
Allah like the meaning the message of it
but like the choice of words we know
that from because when we analyze like
the you know obviously the Hadith their
structure their grammar is different
from what's in the Quran what what's but
what's exactly different if Muhammad
says
off topic now no no no like this this is
this is right on the the meat of the
issue if Muhammad says Allah says this
and then starts quoting Allah how do we
know you're saying that he's not quoting
Allah
verbatim like I mean like for example
like yeah we we couldn't recite so what
the prophet recites and like says in
Hadith we couldn't recite that in other
prayers and so like yeah it has c l a
degree in that sense and you you not
reciting it in your prayers doesn't
negate it being verbate in what Allah
says
though how do you know that when
Muhammad says in the Hadith Allah said
this and then quotes him how do you know
that he's not saying what Allah said for
B yeah okay my bad yeah probably is yeah
I mean yeah I mean it makes sense to me
so you have Hadith where Muhammad is
quoting Allah but it doesn't make it
into the Quran and then you have
obviously the Quran Muhammad's quoting
Allah but you know it's in the Quran
right so similarly I'm
asking div that's just Divine wisdom in
it what what goes where I mean like we
can't really maybe go go to like delve
into that you know I mean that part part
of the belief is you know like believing
in the Unseen you know like but any like
the point being like you know even inah
Isam he's saying you know I've be like
commanded by Allah to you know be good
to my mother to you know establish the
prayer you know give charity fast this
and that and obviously worship one God
alone so like yeah so they would make up
the contents of theil so how do you know
what words of Jesus would make up the
contents of the D when the Quran doesn't
tell
you but then if if the Quran was
completely telling us theil then you
know then basically it's you know giving
us two Revelations the main focus is on
the Quran but obviously there's there's
like passages and remnants let me show
you an example referring to the Past
scriptures let me show you an example of
what I'm talking about let me show you
an example of what I'm talking about
thank you go
ahead um what was I doing
oh so here we have
sorry all right so here we have we're
going to go to
serida and we're going to go to
verse 40
45 now just for context is talking about
the Torah and stuff
right right okay and then Allah Allah in
the Quran it tells us what He put in the
Torah he says and we prescribed for them
therein the life for for a life ey for
an eye nose for nose ear for ear tooth
for tooth wounds for retaliation
right so it tells us what's in the
Torah and this actually what we find we
find this in Exodus chapter
so Allah in the Quran is able to tell us
what
specifically is in the
Torah but he doesn't do this for the
inil he doesn't tell us what
specifically is in the
Ino you hear what I'm saying so without
something like this how do you know what
words that Jesus said belonged in the
inel and wasn't just you know maybe a
Hadith of his a soona of Jesus if you
will because then it then it wouldn't be
quot in the
Quran it would he did the same for the
Torah say again he did the same for the
Torah so the the Quran can quote the
Torah the Revelation in the Torah and
still be the Quran so it can it can
quote what's in the inil tell us what's
in the inil specifically yeah but you
Saidi like that's what I'm saying like
the a Hadith like so like a saying of
Moses is outside of the Torah wouldn't
be in the Quran and even that passage
you just shown how do you know that
that's a fragment right that's a
fragment how you know that bro you don't
know
that because you extrapolate he's a
prophet of Allah he's obviously been
commanded to do certain things and it
will be consistent with you know similar
to the Contex of the Quran where you
know let's try to progress this a little
bit so so the angel is a revelation
given to Jesus he went around preaching
it and teaching right do you believe
that it was written
eventually uh yeah I think it's in the
Quran yeah isn't it like they recognize
him
uh this Prophet the another Prophet who
they find written with them in the Tor
and theel Tor and the gospel y yeah yeah
but you know also like yeah chapter
sorry chapter
246 also says further on that they but
they hide but they hide this yeah they
try to hide some of the truth and stuff
like that so that obviously then that
you know you can extrapolate from there
you know there's obvious Distortion this
and that so they're trying yeah hiding
hiding doesn't mean Distortion if I if I
try to if I hide it's a form of
distortion no no it's not bro I mean if
you if you want to don't distorting the
truth if you if you giving part truth
okay then then then sure uh distorting
the truth meaning not revealing all of
the truth of what it said sure right but
that's that's not a textual Distortion
that's more so a like for example
there's actually an example of them
trying to hide the truth when um they
brought um some adulterers to Muhammad
and they wanted a judgment from Muhammad
and Muhammad said what does the Torah
say and they brought the Torah and when
they brought the Torah when the guy was
reading it he put his hand over the
verse of stoning in the Torah tried to
hide it um and the companions called him
out for was like Hey move your hand he's
trying to hide the verse and so they saw
that it was it was uh you know it was
stoning so we see them trying to conceal
or hide the truth of the Judgment but
and and not trying to adhere to it that
doesn't mean the text doesn't exist that
doesn't mean the verse is gone if they
try to hide it or conceal it you know
what I'm saying so it's not that that
that do that incident is well documented
but that doesn't mean that is the only
instance that would have happened like
when the Quran mentions it it doesn't
mean like that is just a specific
instance it's not and it's not going to
give you the details like you know like
like in an academic way where you know
like there's been a
textual you know Distortion and well
fortunately for us we have the context
of when they try to hide we we have an
exact context and never do we see the
Quran talk about a textual Distortion of
of the book never so with this being
said
withing one second one second now with
the NGO being written the next question
comes who wrote
it who
wrote or who do you think would have WR
the Disciples of Jesus I agree 100% see
you and I agree that Jesus went around
preaching the gospel and that his
disciples would have been the ones wrote
it down we agreed we're two for two so
far right but and do you also agree then
you know what what I was pointing to
earlier like um it would be like you
know similar to what the Quran States
now established prayer you know first
and foremost worship Allah
Alone um you know give zaka give charity
I would agree that the gospel would have
the teaching of theology it will teach
about God and monotheism it'll teach
about prayer it'll teach these things
yes I agree that's hopefully You' got
your answer that you've been looking for
on you know multiple Muslim well not yet
we the only thing so far is that we
we're speculating on what the
inel is right because we're we're we're
we're inferring and we're coming
together we know that Jesus preached it
we know that it was written by his
disciples okay yeah I mean you know
that's what the Quran encourages to do
you know like people of uh you know
people of you know don't these people
Ponder so you have to like yeah you have
to extrapolate not spell you literally
yes we got to think so now that we're
doing this so then we know that the
disciples wrote it so then is it fair to
conclude that I have the inel today in
my
Bible probably remnants of it
yeah
remnants POS of
it okay so if you say that I have parts
of the inil in my Bible this means that
you know what the inil actually is and
you can point to it and say see this is
the part that you still have in your NGO
or in your yeah you still have in your
NG Avery and this is the part that's not
in the NGO this is something that they
added so you'll be able to show me
that right yeah so like yeah Surah maram
verse 31 where you know hea goes through
all the you know list of things that
he's been commanded to do that's the
Quran Sur Mariam is the Quran not the
not the
in yeah but that's what I'm saying
that's the according to us that would be
like the content of
the and then you know yeah where he's
been where the Trinity's been introduced
yeah that's what we say you know but
brother these These are you're just
assuming these things because you're a
Muslim and you disagree with these
things how do you know this wasn't in
theel or what was in theel do you have
something to point to that you can be
like look Avery see this is the and this
is what it says what you have is part of
it see it matches right there but then
here it doesn't match there it matches
this doesn't match like do you can you
do that for
me like like the Ten Commandments to 10
commandments aren't the N that's
Torah I mean yeah I mean to be my mind
like I'm not well versed with the Bible
you know it's
okay to look into that but okay in terms
of like yeah that's my position you know
the contents of the will be similar to
the Quran and you know what what's
revealed for example what if I said this
what if I said this to you just for an
example thought
experiment let's say I said what you
have of the Quran you don't have the
full Quran you only have remnants of it
you have parts of it what what would you
say to me as in
response we've got the manuscripts
dating back to you know the time of
prophet Muhammad then after that plus we
have you know the oral transmission
which is the first safeguarding measure
plus other you know other other OB Allah
himself he promises in the Quran that I
reveal this Quran and I will guard it
and he's guarding it through you know
memorization like obvious even now
there's billions of memorizers in around
the world very good and so with what you
have
manuscripts oral Traditions stuff like
that what would you expect from me if
I'm coming to you with all your
manuscripts and your old tradition and I
have the audacity to tell you hey man
you only have remnants you only have
parts of the Quran you don't have the
full Quran what will you expect from
me obviously you'll be
this in disagreement but then again
isn't isn't isn't there like uh what
would you expect from me you're the one
I'm the one coming to you saying you
don't have the full Quran bro you only
have parts of it you tell me wait hold
on a second I have manuscripts we have
oral tradition all the way that traces
all the way back to Muhammad what are
you talking about this is what we have
what will you expect from me if I'm
claiming that you only have parts of the
Quran what would you expect what would
you want from
me I'm I'll be fuming on
you okay you'll be fuming but what would
you want from
me
evidence
evidence you would want evidence and the
evidence that you would want you know
which is fair is you would want me to
bring you a manuscript of the full Quran
that I'm talking about about to that
traces all the way back to Muhammad and
the companions that shows that what you
have is only parts of what I'm talking
about
right right say again uh car in the last
bit say again you would you would want
me to show you manuscripts of this
original full Quran that I'm talking
about to show you that what you have
only is part of the fool right you would
want me to show you these manuscripts
and the evidence of what I'm talking
about
right wellit in other case more than
manuscripts is uh memorization or of
course you would you would want to see
this evidence right right now what would
you say to me if I couldn't what what
would you say to me if I was like yeah I
don't I don't have any manuscripts of
this you know full Quran this original
full Quran um to show you that you only
have manuscripts of the fool I don't
have any manuscripts evidence I honestly
don't even have an oral tradition of
this Quran that I'm talking about what
would you say
then would you say that I'm full of
crap like the Arab culture obviously
like you know writing things down was
introduced much later you know is more
of an oral tradition they were
memorizes and no nowhere in the Bible it
claims to be you know that we' revealed
this and you know we will guard it you
all over the place it does it says that
all scriptures God breathed and and
breathed out by the Holy Spirit but
specifically that's not answering the
question I asked you brother I asked you
what would you say to me if when you
wanted the evidence and you asked me for
the manuscripts and the oral tradition
of this original Quran that I'm saying
is full that you only have parts of what
if you you I I say I don't have anything
what if you see I don't have no evidence
I don't have no manuscripts I don't have
any oral tradition of this original
Quran I'm telling you about what would
you say to
me in this hypothetical
mhm
Distortion you would say that I'm
bringing a distorted
argument if I don't if if I don't have
the full Quran you think if
I don't have this quote unquote full
Quran I'm coming to you and I'm telling
you hey Nas you don't have the full
Quran you only have remnants of it you
only have Parts okay you don't have the
full
Quran and then you want evidence from me
okay show me this full Quran show me the
full one this original whole Quran give
me the manuscripts show me the oral
tradition and I tell you I don't have
that I don't have any oral tradition to
back up what I'm saying I don't have no
textual tradition to back up what I'm
saying about this original Quran what
would you say to me
then yeah that you haven't got nothing
to compare with because you yeah so then
would you just dismiss me like like Shoe
Fly get out of my face talking out the
side of my neck
a silly it's a silly claim that I'm
bringing with no substance and evidence
is that what you tell
me now good now let's exit out of this
thought
experiment you're telling me that I only
have remnants of this real I only have
parts of it but you have no manuscript
tradition of this that you're talking
about you have no oral tradition of this
that you're talking about so then I can
just dismiss what you're saying as silly
and lacking substance
right yes but don't your own like
biblical Scholars differ on you know the
number of books that make up the Bible
it's not about that we're not talking
about Canon just like there's Islamic
scholars that disagreed on the chapters
of the Quran some had 116 some had 112
some had 114 you know so but that that's
not the argument here so you said sure
yes you said yes I can just dismiss your
claim dismiss your argument because it's
baseless no evidence no
substance now because of that Nas I
would encourage you to never use an
argument that's baseless that has no
evidence you have no evidence to say
that I only have remnants of the NGO
because you don't have the inil to
compare it to you don't have manuscript
tradition or oral tradition to compare
with my inil to tell me that I only have
parts of the real one you get what I'm
saying so don't say that anymore I see I
feel
you and this is this is a a big claim
that a lot of Muslims have adopted and
they've been you know you know they've
been trained to to think this way and to
say this but they don't realize that
what they're saying is silly it's
baseless it has no substance and no
evidence to
it so that's that's my mission is to get
you to just think a little
differently but yeah I did answer your
question with regards to the contents of
theel
and it's it's the it's the yeah it's the
Trinity thing you know for all we know
since what I have is the Gospel of Jesus
written by Matthew Mark Luke and John
the Trinity was in the inil it's part of
the inil that's what Jesus
taught yeah we're definitely disagree
with there I know you disagree with that
but you have no evidence even even even
the scripture like you know even the one
I'm pointing to you to you know
s but again that's just the Quran that
has no no bearing on what theil says see
I have theil I have the Gospel of Jesus
written by Matthew Mark L and John and
in the gospel Jesus teaches that the
father Son and Holy Spirit are one
that's what he teaches he says go out
and make disciples baptize in the name
one name of the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit this is what Jesus
teaches so in the gospel we have the
trinity in the inil we have the Trinity
and you can't say we
don't the only thing you can say is you
know what as a Muslim I disagree with
that but if you're going to say that the
you know the
N
convention the Council of NAA the
Trinity was before the Council of NAA
brother I'm talking about the original s
like was formalized then
no the Council of NAIA had to do with
the deity of Christ and whether he was
co-s substantial with the father or a
Lesser God a lesser being than the
father
and so the Christians the the church
Bishops were arguing against a a heretic
named Aras and his Squad and they
refuted him with
scripture so so this is where we're at
man as as a thinker and I appreciate you
following like you know rocking with me
all the way up until this point as a
thinker as a critical thinker and as one
who prides thems in honesty and Truth we
don't want to sit no falsehood we don't
want to have false thinking we want to
be real with ourselves and with truth
and with
reality you can no longer say that I
don't have the inel because you have no
evidence
otherwise and then
two all you know is that in the inil is
what it teaches the Trinity is true
Jesus was crucified Jesus is the Divine
son of the father who's one in essence
with the father and the spirit this is
what the gospel teaches
and this is the gospel that the Quran
confirms no but the Quran also you know
the Quran teaches the opposite to that
and what's you're right you're right on
the money the Quran teaches the opposite
of that and now you have entered the
Islamic dilemma here's the problem the
Quran
says it claims that it
confirms the gospel it confirms it right
all over the place chapter 2:s 41 it
came confirming that which is already
with you 71 157 Muhammad is in the Torah
and the gospel with them chapter 2 ver
89 the Quran came confirming what is
with them right so they have the gospel
the Quran confirms it it says it's true
let the people of the Gospel judge by
what Allah has revealed therein 5:47
whoever doesn't judge by what Allah has
revealed they're the wrongdoers they
have the gospel so the Quran says the
gospel is true that they have however
the Quran disagrees with the gospel it
says Jesus wasn't crucified says God is
not a trinity he's only one person um
he's not a father right Jesus is not his
son he neither begets nor is he begotten
so the Quran contradicts the gospel in
these matters while at the at the same
time saying that the gospel is
true therefore the Quran is false for
contradicting a book that's true that it
says it's true let me explain that if
the gospel is false then the Quran is
still false because it's saying that a
false book is
true let me explain that let me explain
it like a more like goad go ahead go
ahead common everyday scenario basically
so for example if I you know like we we
all Buy stuff off Amazon and stuff yeah
MH and then you know we get the product
home yeah y y and then I go on you know
to onto the website to write a
review now some of the parts of the you
know like for example I bu bought a sofa
of Amazon some of the things you know I
like the color I like
the you know the comfort of it but
there's other parts of it I I would
disagree you know in part of my overall
review of this
product so that doesn't mean I'm
affirming the whole thing
or you know denying the whole thing but
I'm
like you know like my in my review I'm B
I'm giving I'm giving pros and cons to
this
product if you understand the you know
analogy yeah and here's let me go with
your analogy the Quran never does that
the Quran never says this part is good
and this part isn't matter of fact the
Quran goes solely against people who do
that let me show you this is what the
Quran says this is chapter 2 verse 85
okay it says yet ye it is who slay each
other and drive out a party of your
people from their homes talking about
the Jews supporting one another against
them by sin and
transgression and if they came to you as
captives ye would Ransom them whereas
their exposion was itself unlawful for
you now here's the part I need you to
pay attention this is a relevant
part believe you in part of the
scripture and disbelieve in part
thereof and what is the reward of those
who do
so save um I don't know what that word
means but it's basically trouble or
disgrace in this life like Old English
yeah yeah it is let me let me give
another one another a simpler one um
let's see what Sai International
does all here here it is so do you
believe so do you believe in part of the
scripture and disbelieve in part then
what is the recompense for those who do
that among you except disgrace in the
worldly life and on the day of
Resurrection they will be sent back the
severest punishment and Allah is not
unaware of what you do so those people
who want to leave a
review and like some of the parts of the
scripture but disagree with other parts
of the scripture Allah says in the Quran
that that person is a disgrace and they
will have the severest of punishment on
the day of
Resurrection wait wait is the context
the Quran here or like the previous
context is the previous scriptures the
Torah so but this is a principle that
like goes all the way through you can't
like the the Quran says this elsewhere
in chapter 15: 91 it said says um that
they make the Quran into shreds they
make the Quran into shreds now before
that it talks about how they're picking
and
choosing with the Quran it's like
wholesome you it's you know it's all or
nothing it's the same with all the
scriptures the same with the Torah here
it's all or nothing you can't pick and
choose what you believe in you have to
believe in it
all and if you don't Allah being the
Divine Source he knows you know you know
where where they you know manipulated it
so that's why it approves you know where
it's like saying you know look you know
look back to the previous scriptures or
ask them about this there it's affirming
it but where he's criticizing them is
where you know they've distorted it you
know that's that's what I take from it n
how does that make sense I need you to
think with me so do you believe in part
of the scripture and disbelieve in part
and then people who do that get punished
and are disgraced so you mean to tell me
that after Allah has said that who
whoever's picking and choosing what they
believe in the scripture and reject then
they they are disgraced he's also
telling you that you can pick and choose
what you believe in the
scriptures not from the direct
Revelation no of course not okay so the
Torah is the revelation of Allah the
injil the revelation of Allah the Quran
the revelation of Allah you cannot do
this with any of those books you can't
believe in part and then reject other
parts you can't do that to any of his
Revelation to any of the
scripture can't do that I agree with
that so you can't go come to the inil
and say oh well you know there's some
parts that are good and then other parts
that are not you can't do that the Quran
tells you not to do
that well that's what I'm saying where
we're worshiping one God like you know
in the Ten Commandments and in the Quran
and
what you know the inil from what what we
know of it is is exactly the same but
then the Trinity theology that that is
that's completely you know it's just out
there that's in the
injil so the fact that the Quran affirms
the injil as the word of God however
within the inil it teaches that God is a
trinity shows that the Quran is false
for affirming a book that teaches the
Trinity because it contradicts
it or if the Trinity is false
and the then theil is teaching false
things then the Quran is false for
saying that theil is
true either way you go the Quran is
false both ways if the Bible's good the
Quran is false because it contradicts
the Bible if the Bible's bad that the
Quran is false for saying the Bible's
good that's the
Dilemma yeah I like I said you know it's
basically it's like a review you it's
said even when academic reviews happen
they don't agree with everything what
their predecessor but the Quran says it
does the Quran says it agrees with
everything and you can't not agree with
something no the last scripture you
showed the last passage you showed so
that's like regarding the Revelation
everything obviously whatever Allah's
revealed yeah regarding the scripture
it's it's regarding the scripture what
do you mean yeah Revelation scripture
being I'm using to change believe so
according to this passage can you pick
and choose what you believe in the
scripture No not if it's from Allah then
don't do
it don't do
it I'm not you
are I don't want you to be disgraced in
this life or the next so don't do it
don't pick and Sho I feel for you
because you know Jesus he's GNA he's
gonna he's going to disown
you when he comes back as well you know
he's a Mercy to Mankind because when he
comes back in his second
coming what's the mercy that he brought
to
mankind it when you went
when claim to follow him that if they
accept him as the prophet of Allah you
know then they'll be saved as a mercy
but oh so he bring so so he brings them
salvation if they take him as as the
prophet of Allah yeah in his second come
in yeah
really so obviously salvation in the
sense that you know so Jesus gives
salvation he'll be following this the
Sharia of the final Prophet but Jesus
basically he'll basically come to
correct and you know like this own the
people who took him as you know as a god
besides Allah is that what he's coming
to do in his second coming yeah and OB
amongst other things you know like
killing the you know the deal and so on
but yeah okay
let me read you
something I want to read you something
bro I think you'll find it
fascinating I find it
fascinating and then we could uh go
ahead and wrap it
up from from our sources
on from your source
okay from your Source
um what was it oh bukari 74 98 I
think it's actually quite fascinating
blew my mind when I saw it not gonna
lie roll
I couldn't believe it I was like no
way is a s
948 what's the Hadith a come on use your
skills I know I'm training to be a ha of
of Hadith but I'm not quite there
just I'm not quite there just yet dang
it what is it then hm
let me see well not many Muslims you
know have of the had you
know except from like M
but you know like really who really do
study you know like that's a separate
branch of the Islamic
Sciences
study
direct Allah's revealed this Quran he
will guard it you know that claims that
it's not in any of the previous books
but yeah you were going to show me
something
yeah I want to show you something
man just give me some give me some
patience
here what did I put in for it to come up
um I have found it with
me okay I found
it I found
it
okay let me just show this really quick
here
here s Muslim
2569 you with me yeah
yeah wait wait wait I we gotta read it
slowly together all loud I'll read it so
it says uh Allah's messenger said verily
Allah the exalted and glorious would say
on the day of Resurrection oh son of
Adam I was sick but you did but you did
not not visit me this is Allah speaking
Allah's going to say to the son son oh
son of Adam I was sick but you did not
visit me he would say oh my Lord how
could I visit you whereas you are lord
of the worlds thereupon he would say
didn't you know that such and such
servant of mine was sick but you did not
visit
him
mm sorry and were you not aware of this
that if you had visited him you would
have found me by
him oh son of Adam I asked food from you
but you did not feed me he would say my
Lord how could I feed you whereas you
are the lord of the worlds he said
didn't you know that such and such
servant of mine asked food from you but
you did not feed him and you were not
aware were you not aware that if you had
fed him you would have found him by my
side un oh son of Adam I asked drink
from you but you did not provide me he
would say my Lord how could I provide
you whereas you are the lord of the
worlds thereupon he would say such and
such servant of mine asked you for a
drink but you did not provide him and
had you provided him drink you would
have found him near me so basically if
you would have
fed or gave drink or visited the sick of
the Servants of of Allah it's basically
doing it to him
right that's what he says here
right you there
n Nas you
there this is important man I need you
to get hello yeah can you hear
me yeah you just call yeah I was getting
a call yeah go go ahead yeah okay did
you did you hear the Hadith at least
though yeah yeah I heard the Hadith yeah
I can see as well yeah okay so yeah so
Allah says if you would have visited the
sick you would have been visiting me if
you would have gave drink to this person
to my servant you would have given that
drink to me if you would have right gave
food to the to my hungry servant you
would have been giving it to me right
that's what he says that's the point all
right so it's interesting because we see
where this actually comes from
where Allah says this now tell me if
this sounds
familiar it says when the son of man
comes in his glory and all the angels
with him this is Jesus speaking about
himself then he will sit on his glorious
Throne before him will be gathered all
the nations and he will separate people
one from another as a Shepherd separates
the sheep from the goats and he will
place the sheep on his right but the
goats on his left then the king will say
to those on his right so Jesus is the
king of the day of judgment
and he says come you who are blessed by
my father right exactly yeah Subhan
Allah like I'm clearing Allah from the
blasphemy you just said but what do you
mean this is Jesus ain't me this is
Jesus I'm saying like Allah is above
what you saying go subh this is this is
Jesus saying is okay look Jesus says
that he's the king of the day of
judgment and he will say to those on his
right come you who are blessed by my
father inherit the Kingdom prepared from
the found foundation of the world for I
was hungry and you gave me food I was
thirsty and you gave me drink I was a
stranger and you welcomed me I was naked
and you clothed me I was sick and you
visited me I was in prison and you came
to me then the righteous will answer him
saying Lord when did we see you hungry
and feed you or thirsty and give you
drink and when do we see you a stranger
and welcome you or naked and clothe you
and when did we see you sick or in
prison and visit you and the King will
answer them truly I say to you as you
did it to one of the least of these my
brothers you did it to
me so here we have Jesus saying this and
then Allah 600 years
later quotes what Jesus
said showing that Allah is claiming to
be Jesus who's going to come and say
this to their to his servants
maybe Jesus said this to his disciples
about Allah he said it to his disciples
about himself he says the son of man is
going to come in his glory with the
angels and he's going to sit on his
glorious Throne he's talking about
himself so Jesus is the Lord the king of
the day of judgment who's going to sit
on his glorious throne and judge Mankind
and he's going to decide who goes to
heaven and hell and what he's going to
say to them is for I was hungry and you
gave me no food I was thirsty you gave
me no drink I was a stranger and you did
not welcome me naked you did not clothe
me sick and you did not visit me they
will say Lord when were you hungry and
we didn't feed you when were you thirsty
and we didn't give you drink when were
you naked and we didn't clothe you when
were you sick and we didn't visited you
he's going to say then he will answer
them saying truly I say to you you did
not do it to one of the least of these
so you did not do it to me why is Allah
copying words of Jesus in The Book of
Matthew if you if you replace the son of
man or son of you know what was it son
of man with Allah
then yeah maybe that's what Jesus said
about Allah to his you know his
followers I mean oh may maybe if we
maybe if you distort the text then maybe
you can make it fit to Islam huh so so
what you're saying is is you as a Muslim
you have to corrupt what Jesus says in
order for it to fit Islam so who's the
one distorting the book book is it you
or me well I mean like for all given all
the lengthy discussion we've gone
through you know I mean that could be
that someone's just inserted that in you
know they called him you know I
speculating that so yeah I couldn't like
go you know much any concrete I just
wanted to show you what Jesus is going
to do on the day of judgment which Allah
takes from Jesus and applies it I mean
in a way yeah in harmony you know both
prophets will preach this about Allah
yeah Mak well no Jesus is preaching this
about himself
Muhammad is saying that this is about
Allah quoting Matthew so he's basically
saying that Jesus is Allah in Matthew
yeah can you give me that worse of you
know from is it from the Bible obvious
I'll have to dig around on that sah
Muslim sah Muslim no the one you know
mention you mention about Jesus Oh in
the Bible oh it's Matthew chapter
25 starting at starting at verse 31 say
again starting at verse 31 verse 31 yeah
thank you so 31 and you want to read all
the way
down all right man cool appreciate you
coming I love your attitude man it was a
good conversation man I appreciate it
likewise pleasure take care mate take
care man